well over half of Americans are being
told not to go out to slow the spread of
the coronavirus stay at home orders or
directives are in effect in 32 states
and Washington DC Florida has the fifth
highest number of cases in the US as men
well Bojorquez reports the governor's
response has been limited we want to win
the fight against kovat 19 Florida's
governor is ordering a handful of
counties to shelter at home including
the state's largest miami-dade and
Broward which already had similar orders
to begin with this is the time to do the
right thing listen to all your local
officials but critics point to scenes
like this one a closed speech on one
side and open one on the other
to show the piecemeal approach may not
work still officials and counties with
restrictions are making a point of
enforcing them after defined social
distancing guidelines by holding packed
church services on Sunday the pastor of
the river at Tampa Bay Church was
arrested and charged with two
misdemeanors the safety and well-being
of our community must always come first
and it's still unclear where passengers
aboard the sand dam and Rotterdam cruise
ships will dock two people aboard the
sand dam have tested positive for Cove
at 19 and 189 passengers have reported
flu-like symptoms
four have died it is roughly two days
from South Florida we would like to have
medical personnel simply dispatched to
that ship
governor de Santa said letting the ship
dock in Fort Lauderdale would be a
mistake what his decision would be if
his mother was on this ship Andrea
Anderson and her husband Rob have been
traveling on the Zaandam since March 7th
how would he feel if another passenger
dies because they are not able to
receive the proper medical care on that
they would have received in the hospital
Governor De Santis has also said he
would like to save hospital beds in
South Florida for Floridians and pointed
out there are several foreign nationals
on that ship currently there are 138 US
citizens aboard the Zaandam gale
boy man well thank you very much